Willkommen an der Militärakademie in
Wiener Neustadt. Mein Name ist Oberst
Markus Reisner, ich bin der Leiter der Forschungs-
und Entwicklungsabteilung der Militärakademie und
heute am vierzigsten Tag seit Kriegsbeginn
wollen wir uns kurz ansehen wie sich die
Lage in der Ukraine im Moment darstellt. Dazu
habe ich eine kleine Präsentation mitgebracht,
die ich nur mit ihnen durchgehen möchte. Beginnen
wir kurz noch einmal mit einem Geländevergleich,
damit uns bewusst wird wie groß die Ukraine
eigentlich ist. Ich habe hier Österreich in seinen
Grenzen in die Ukraine hineingelegt, das ist
wichtig zum Verständnis im Hinblick auf die von
den Russen eingenommene Gebiete, beziehungsweise
auch im Hinblick auf die Gebiete die jetzt von den
Ukrainern wieder zurück in Besitz genommen werden
konnten. Gehen wir noch einmal kurz zurück zur
Ausgangssituation des 24. Februar. Die russische
Seite hat circa 200.000 Soldaten an der Grenze
zur Ukraine zusammengezogen, die sie zum Einsatz
gebracht haben. In folgenden Schwergewichtsräumen
westlich und nordostwärts von Kiew im Raum
Charkiw entlang der Kontaktlinie sowie südlich
im Raum auf der Krim. Nicht vergessen, aber nicht
eingesetzt, dürfen wir auch jene Kräfte die sich
im Raum Belarus bei Presz befinden. Der Beginn
war der Versuch Kiew in einem Enthauptungsschlag
rasch einzunehmen und zwar zentrale Elemente
wie zum Beispiel den Maidan oder das Stürzen
der Regierung. Hier wurde diese Luftlandung
von der 31 Airborne-Brigade durchgeführt, die
gescheitert ist. Das Ergebnis war, dass zwar die
Luftlandung nicht funktioniert hat, die russischen
Streitkräfte aber in diesen Räumen relativ rasch
versucht haben vorzumarschieren. Sie haben dabei
die Städte links oder rechts liegen gelassen und
sind rasch in die Tiefe des Landes vorgestoßen.
Sehen wir uns noch einmal die Kämpfe der letzten
fünf Wochen an und versuchen wir herauszufinden
warum die ukrainischen Streitkräfte dieses
mal erfolgreich waren. 2014 beim Einmarsch
der russischen Truppen im Donbas war
es so dass die ukrainische Streitkräfte
versucht haben die russischen Verbände
in grenznähe aufzuhalten. Sie wurden oft
umfasst und eingekesselt. Diesmal hat man
die russischen Verbände hereingelassen das
Land hat sie dann begonnen zu verzögern und
hat ihre Versorgungskonvois angegriffen das
haben vor allem ukrainische Spezialkräfte
aber auch die Nationalgarde durchgeführt.
Zusätzlich kam es zum Einsatz von Drohnen wie
zum Beispiel der türkischen Bayaktar oder auch
von gezielter Artillerie. Das hatte einen
massiven Abnutzungseffekt für die russische
Seite. Das erinnert doch sehr an das Konzept der
Raumverteidigung in Österreich. Damals war es so,
dass man versucht hat gegen die übermächtige
Sovietarmee eine valide Abwehrstrategie zu
entwickeln und man hat gesagt wir versuchen
die sowjetischen Streitkräfte hereinzulassen
sie dann den Schlüsselzonen zur bekämpfen und
zu verzögern und dann mit Jagdkampfkräften
ihre Versorgungslinien abzuschneiden. Die
Idee war vor allem die der Abschreckung,
das heißt man sollte es dem Gegner zeigen dass es
nicht möglich ist rasch, quasi, durch Österreich
durchzumarschieren. Das zweite wesentliche Element
für den Erfolg der ukrainischen Einsatzführung war
aber sicherlich, und ist bis jetzt, der Austausch
von Aufklärungsdaten. Wir wissen dass pro Tag
zwischen 10 und 15 Aufklärungsmaschinen der
NATO und der USA im Raum westlich, nördlich
und südlich der Ukraine sich befinden diese
Aufklärungsflugzeuge und auch Drohnen generieren
Daten. Diese Daten werden dann in ukrainischen
Streitkräfte gegeben die darauf basierend ganz
gezielt Targeting durchführen können. Einer der
Gründe warum bis jetzt sieben Generäle und 15
Oberste in den Kampfhandlungen gefallen sind und
hier an dieser Slide erkennt man noch einmal die
sehr gut die Intensität dieser Aufklärungsflüge
im Raum westlich bzw südlich von der Ukraine.
Am Übergang von der vierten zur fünften Woche gab
es ein signifikantes Ereignis. Ein Briefing des
russischen Verteidigungsministeriums.
In diesem Briefing hat das russische
Verteidigungsministerium das erste mal gezeigt wie
sie den Vormarsch ihrer Truppen tatsächlich sehen
was man an dieser Karte erkennen kann. Dieser
Vormensch korreliert auch mit dem Ergebnis der
Aufklärung der westlichen Staaten wie man hier
an diesem Beispiel aus Großbritannien sehen
kann. Wir erkennen also der Vormarsch auf Kiew
die Kämpfe bei Charkiw in Donbas und im Süden.
Wie man erkennen kann, war es bei den Briefings
so, dass die russische Seite vermittelt hat,
dass sie eigentlich gar nicht vorhatte
Kiew oder die anderen Städte anzugreifen,
sondern sich immer auf den Donbas konzentrieren
wollte. Der Donbas soll nun auch das Ziel sein
der Operationsführung und es scheint durchaus
denkbar, dass man in den nächsten Wochen bis zum
neunten Mai, dem Tag des Sieges, versucht hier
eine Entscheidung herbeizuführen. Die russische
Seite hatte also begonnen die Nordfront
auszudünnen und sich zurückzuziehen und
Kräfte zusammen zuziehen in Hinblick auf eine
mögliche Operation die sicher der Einkesselung
der ukrainischen Streitkräfte im Donbas dient.
Zusätzlich wird man sich im Süden bei Kerson aber
auch in Charkiv weiter konsolidieren um diese
Einsatzführung zu unterstützen. Die ukrainische
Seite steht vor der Herausforderung einer
möglichen Einkesselung ostwärts das Dnepr. Aus
dieser muss sie entkommen, um quasi vor allem an
der günstigen Verteidigungslinie des Dnepr weiter
verteidigen zu können. Sehen wir uns das noch
einmal im Vergleich mit anderen Karten an. Hier
die Karte vom dritten März, wo man hier massiv
den Vormarsch von russischer Seite erkennen kann.
Im Vergleich zum zweiten April, wo man sieht,
dass der Norden von Kiew bereits beginnt sich
auszudünnen, was man auch auf dieser letzten Karte
vom dritten April sehen kann, wo der Nordbereich
von Kiew bereits leer von russischen Truppen ist
und auch ein Zurückgehen der russischen Truppen
aus dem Raum Cherniv und Ssume erkennbar ist.
Die Grundherausforderungen der ukrainischen Seite
sind unverändert die erste Herausforderung ist das
Halten von Kiew als politisches und militärisches
Zentrum des Landes. Das ist gelungen und das ist
im Moment auch als klarer Sieg für die Ukraine
anzusprechen. Die zweite Herausforderung, dass
wo offensichtlich das Schwergewicht der Russen
nun abzielt, ist die Gefahr eines Einschließens
entlang der Kontaktlinie. Hier erkennen wir,
dass die russische Seite bei Ysiom aber auch im
Süden versucht quasi diesen Kessel entstehen zu
lassen. Die dritte Herausforderung ist, nach
wie vor, dass wir Kräfte im Raum Preszt haben,
auf der belarussischen Seite, wo nicht
erkennbar ist, ob die einen Zusatzauftrag
in Zukunft durchführen werden, das könnte
zum Beispiel ein begrenzter Angriff sein,
um Panik im Westen des landes entstehen zu
lassen. Und die vierte Herausforderung ist
nach wie vor der Umstand, dass die russische
Seite bereits den Dnepr überschritten hat,
im Raum Cherson und möglicherweise Unterstützend
auch zur Einkesselung entlang des Westufers
vorstoßen könnte. Wenn wir uns vor Augen führen,
dass die ukrainische Streitkräfte die quantitativ
stärksten Streitkräfte Europas waren, so ist
diese Folie sehr aufschlusskräftig, das ist eine
Folie der russischen Seite, die die verfügbaren
Kräfte ukrainischer Seite sowie die aus ihrer
Sicht erfolgten Abnutzungen darstellen. Man kann
erkennen, dass die ukrainischen Streitkräfte
massiv aufgestellt waren. Jedoch ist das Problem,
dass seit dem 24. eine stete Abnutzung passiert,
das heißt wir haben also laufend Fliegerangriffe
aber auch der Einsatz von Präzisionswaffen,
der den ukrainischen Streitkräften Verluste
beibringt. Wir haben also das Problem,
dass wir vor allem diese schweren Waffen
nicht mehr in dieser Ausprägung so wie am
Beginn sehen und wenn die Ukrainer es wollten,
dass sie quasi ihr Land wieder zurückerobern,
bräuchten sie gerade diese massiven Waffensysteme
um das durchführen zu können. Die Frage, die auch
zu stellen ist, ist die nach Verfügbarkeit
von Präzisionswaffen. Wir wissen, dass auf
der ukrainischen Seite das Arsenal zunehmend
weniger wird. Das sind vor allem Toschka-U,
ballistische Raketen, aber auch verfügbare Drohen
wie zum Beispiel die Bayraktar. Auf der russischen
Seite haben wir mittlerweile über 1400 eingesetzte
Präzisionswaffen. Dazu zählen Marschflugkörper,
wie zum Beispiel vom Kalibr, aber auch
Hyperschallwaffen, wie vom Typ Kinschal,
sowie ballistische Raketen wie zum Beispiel
vom Typ Iskandar und nicht zu vergessen der
Einsatz von Drohnen wie zum Beispiel hier dieseOrion oder auch jene Systeme ist vom Typ Forpost,
die ganz gezielt die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte bewirken können.
Die Frage ist, wie geht es weiter? Unisono
können wir sagen, dass der kurze, intensive
Krieg offensichtlich nicht funktioniert hat. Der
Blitzkrieg ist gescheitert, wir befinden uns nun
in einem Abnutzungskrieg, wo es entscheidend
ist, welche Seite quasi den längeren Atem hat.
Hier hat man natürlich den Vorteil, auf der
russischen Seite, die massiv an Ressourcen
verfügbar machen kann, während die ukrainische
Seite scheinbar nur begrenzte Ressourcen hat. Wenn
jedoch beide Seiten etwas erreichen wollen, das
sie ihrer Bevölkerung verkaufen können, so scheint
es möglich, dass wir eine Verhandlungslösung
sehen. Wenn jedoch die Unterstützung des Westens
von russischer Seite nicht mehr toleriert
wird, also zunehmende Waffenlieferungen,
da könnte sein, dass der Krieg sich über
regionalisiert, das heißt das kommt dazu,
dass wir zum Beispiel in einem Wirtschaftskrieg
beide Seiten in einer entsprechenden Abnutzung
sehen. Ein mögliches Szenario wäre auch ein
Umsturz, der innerhalb von Russland passiert,
also im Umfeld des Präsidenten. Diese zwei Skizzen
sollen Ihnen kurz darstellen einerseits den
Versuch der NATO massiv ein Abschreckungspotenzial
darzustellen und auf der anderen Seite,
auf dieser chinesischen Karte, interessant
die Einzeichnung zentral, nämlich KHPR,
also Kherrson People's Republic, was eine Idee
dafür sein könnte wie die Nachkriegsordnung von
russischer Seite möglicherweise sich darstellen
wird, also quasi eine Teilrepublik analog zu
den beiden anderen, also im Sinne quasi von
Satellitenstaaten, die von russischer Seite
kontrolliert werden. Damit bin ich am Ende des
Vortrages und mit diesem Bild der verheerenden
Zerstörungen Mariupol möchte ich mich für das
Zuhören bedanken und bis zum nächsten Mal!